le premier SMS de l'histoire est envoyé
sur un téléphone portable de marque
Vodafone en décembre 1992 par un
ingénieur de l'entreprise joyeux Noël
le premier téléphone intelligent a vu le
jour en 1994 un combiné sur son chargeur
appelé Simon de
IBM c'est ce téléphone est écran tactile
qui ouvre la porte de cette nouvelle
façon de communiquer
[Musique]
les SMS pour short Messenger Service ou
texto comme on dit ici et en France et à
partir de 1997 et bien les grands
fabricants de téléphones mobiles à
travers le monde développe une multitude
de modèles le phénomène prend de
l'ampleur si bien qu'on assiste dans les
années 2000 à une saturation du réseau
mobile mondial les soirs de nouvel an il
faut dire qu'il a coûtait moins cher
d'envoyer un message que d'effectuer un
appel téléphonique sur ce tout petit
écran on peut maintenant aussi jouer à
des jeux vidéo viennent aussi les
premiers téléphones permettant la prise
de photo
et en 1999 et bien c'est l'arrivée du
fameux BlackBerry canadien conçu par
resurt in Motion
cet appareil est devenu le choix préféré
des professionnels entre autres en
raison de son clavier et de sa
simplicité d'utilisation
mais c'est en 2007 qui arrive un
événement majeur dans le domaine des
communications c'est la véritable folie
lancement du premier iPhone d'Apple à
New York les gens sont prêts à tout pour
s'en procurer un
je téléphone et maintenant devenu un
petit ordinateur en choix c'est grâce à
ce type de téléphone portable que les
médias sociaux ont aussi pris une telle
ampleur
mais revenons sur le premier message
texte envoyé il y a 30 ans cet objet
numérique dont la propriété est traçable
a été vendu aux enchères en banlieue de
Paris l'an dernier pour la somme de
150000 dollars canadiens un Joyeux Noël
virtuel qui contraste avec les anciens
vœux écrits les fameuses cartes de Noël
livrées au rythme du postier ici jacques
Bissonnet Radio-Canada Montréal